Transcriber: ovgu seker
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Herkese merhabalar, hoş geldiniz.
Bildiğiniz üzere bugünkü konumuz
çıkış noktası, çıkış.
Ben bunun üzerine düşünürken
şeyi fark ettim.
Bir yerden çıkabilmek için aslında
bir yere girmemiz gerekiyor.
Yani bir çıkış noktası yaratabilmemiz için
aynı zamanda bir giriş noktasına da
ihtiyacımız var.
Bunu hatta daha basit bir
şekilde örneklendirebiliriz.
Bir odadan çıkmanız için bir odanın
içerisinde olmanız gerekiyor
Sonra çıktığınız yerden tekrar
başka bir yere geçiyorsunuz.
O başka bir yere geçtiğiniz zaman, tekrar
başka bir yere çıkmış oluyorsunuz.
Bu aslında bir döngü
fakat bu döngüyü yaratırken çok çok farklı
etkenler hayatın içerisinde var oluyor.
Yaşamın kuralı bu çünkü
bazı insanlar kendi çıkış noktalarını
ya da başarılarını yaratırken
bunları sadece kendilerini tatmin
etmek için yaparlar.
Bu hikâye aslında onları çok fazlasıyla
besliyor olabilir.
Onları mutlu ediyor olabilir ama
sürdürülebilir değildir.
Aslında yaşamın en büyük amaçlarından
bir tanesi
yani insanoğlunun biyolojik olarak
var olmasının ya da bütün
canlıların var olmasının sebebi
sürdürülebilir olmamız.
O yüzden fikirlerimiz ve çıkış
noktalarımız
yani başarılarımız da aslında
sürdürülebilir olmalı.
Mesela banka borcunu bitiren bir adamın
da hayatında bir çıkış noktası vardır
çünkü banka borcu bitmiştir.
Mahallesinde bakkal açan adamın
da bir çıkış noktası vardır
çünkü mahallesinde bir girişimcilik
örneği sergilemiştir
ama bu ne kadar sürdürülebilirdir?
Ama bazı insanlar vardır,
onlar kendi çıkış noktalarında
başarılarını bir medeniyete
ve tüm dünyaya mal ederler.
Bu isimlerden bir tanesi --
bugün Sivas’tayım
ve bu topraklarda doğdum, büyüdüm ben.
Bu isimlerden bir tanesi de bu topraklarda
doğdu, bu topraklarda büyüdü
ve yaşama bu topraklarda gözünü yumdu.
Hepiniz onun kim olduğunu biliyorsunuz,
Aşık Veysel Şatıroğlu.
(Alkış)
Fakat şöyle bir durum vardı,
herkes doğar ama o Veysel’di.
Bir de bu cümleyi şöyle tekrarlayabiliriz:
Herkes doğar âmâ o Veysel’di.
Arada çok basit bir nüans
farkı var aslında.
Yaşamımızda da buna benzer nüanslarla
çok fazla karşılaşıyoruz.
Birçoğunun da farkında olmuyoruz.
Müzikte de böyle nüanslar var ve bunlar
aslında bize o hissi, duyguyu veren,
küçük küçük hikâyeleri oluşturan noktalar
ve bu iki bahsettiğim örnek de yani
kurduğum cümle de aslında doğru ve gerçek.
Herkes doğar ama o Veysel,
herkes doğar âmâ o Veysel.
Burada asıl önemli olan sizin nereden
baktığınızla alakalı bir konu.
Yani sizin bakış açınız.
Hani bir örnek verdim ya başta
bir çıkış noktamız var.
Bir kapıyı açtım, başka bir odaya çıktım.
Sadece başka bir odaya çıkmak da
aslında yeterli değil.
Çıktığınız kapıdan hangi açıyla
nereye baktığınız önemli.
Eğer bu tarafa bakarsanız âmâ
bir Veysel görürsünüz.
Ama diğer tarafa bakarsanız özel
Hayatımızda bu küçük noktalar dışarıdan
gelen etkenlerle maalesef çok fazla
bizi yıpratabiliyor, bizi üzebiliyor,
bizim kafamızı da karıştırabiliyor.
Bunlardan sakınabilmek ve
kendi özümüzde yaratmış olduğumuz
o hikâyeyi kurgulayabilmek için
ben kendi hayatım boyunca
hep şunu kendime tekrarladım
ve hep canım sıkıldığında,
başım dara girdiğinde,
moralim bozulduğunda açıp hep onu okudum.
Veysel’in meyve bahçeleri.
Aranızda bilen var mı bilmiyorum
bu hikâyeyi ama var mı?
Hiç yok, süper.
Hikâye şöyle, biliyorsunuz Aşık Veysel’in
toprakla ilgili çok fazla bestesi var
doğa ile ilgili.
Böyle olmasının sebeplerinden bir tanesi
de onun köylü bir yaşam sürmesi.
Yani toprakla sürekli iç içe olması.
Aşık Veysel köyünde bir meyve
bahçesi yetiştirmek istiyor.
Fakat köylüler şunu söylüyor.
“Bizim atamız, dedemiz yıllarca bunu
denedi yapmaya çalıştı.
Burada meyve bahçesi falan yetişmez.”
Aşık Veysel kardeşlerinin de yardımıyla
bu meyve bahçesini oluşturuyor.
Tabii üzerinden zaman geçiyor.
O ağaçlar çiçek açıyor, türlü türlü
meyveler veriyor ve bunları söyleyen
“Olmaz, yapamazsın, edemezsin, ya bizim
yapamadığımızı âmâ bir insan mı yapacak!”
diyen köylüler haliyle utanıyor
ve şunu fark ediyorlar.
Görmemek ile görmeyi istememek arasında
çok büyük bir fark var.
Yani nüans farkları var.
Görmemek bir problem değildir hayatımızda.
En büyük problem kendimizde
ve etrafımızda olan
görmeyi istemeyen insanlar.
İnsanlık varoluşundan beri iyilik ve
kötülük üzerine aslında ikiye ayrıldı
ve çok basit bir şekilde ikiye ayrıldı.
İyiler yeşertti, kötüler kuruttu.
Bütün bu hikâyenin sonunda Veysel
şöyle bir söz de söylüyor:
Hiçbir türlü bulamadım ben beni.
Şimdi hiçbir türlü bulamadım
ben beni diyen bir dünyada,
Veysel’in dediği bu dünyada
kendimize çıkış noktası arıyoruz.
Oysa ki yaşamın bütün anı aslında
bir çıkış noktamız.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)
Bunu almam gerekiyor.